you know in terms of media Andrew
Breitbart was was a mentor uh Andrew
obviously he was kind of known in his
latter days I think more for the
militancy than than when I was very
close with him so for somebody like me
who doesn't who knows more about the
militancy can you tell me what is what
is a great what makes him a great man
what made Andrew great is that he
engaged with everyone I mean everyone so
there are videos of him
rollerblading down the Boulevard and
people would be protesting and he would
literally like rollerblade up to them
and he would say let's go to lunch
together and he would just do this like
that's actually who Andrew was what was
the thinking behind that just just he
was just careless he was he was much
more outgoing than I am actually he was
he was very warm with people like for me
you know I would say that with Andrew I
knew Andrew for say I remember when I
was 16 he passed away when I would have
been 28. so I knew Andrew for 10 12
years and people who met Andrew for
about 10 minutes
new Andrew 99 as well as my new Andrew
because he was just all out front like
everything was out here and he was he
loved talking to people he loved
engaging with people and so this made
him a lot of fun and unpredictable and
fun to watch and all of that and then I
think Twitter got to him I think by you
know Twitter is one of the lessons I
learned from Andrew was the counter
lesson which is Twitter Twitter can
poison you Twitter Twitter can really
wreck you if you spend all day on
Twitter reading the comments and getting
angry at people who are talking about
you it becomes a very difficult life and
I think that you know in the last year
of his life Andrew got very caught up in
that because of a series of sort of
circumstances it can actually affect
your mind it can actually make you
resentful all that kind of stuff I I
tend to agree with that so but but the
lesson that I learned from Andrew is
engage with everybody take joy in sort
of the the mission that you're given and
you can't always fulfill that you know
sometimes it's really rough and
difficult I'm not going to pretend that
it's all fun and and rainbows all the
time because it didn't and some of the
stuff that I have to cover I don't like
and some of the things I have to say I
don't particularly like you know like
that's that happens but it's uh but
that's what I learned from Andrew as far
are sort of other mentors I had some I
had some teachers when I was a kid who
uh you know said things that stuck with
me I had a fourth grade teacher named Mr
nutty who said don't let potential be
written on your Tombstone which was uh
which is a pretty that's a good line
it's a great line particularly to a
fourth grader uh but uh it was that that
you know that was good in 11th grade
English teacher named Anthony Miller who
is terrific really good writer he'd
studied uh with James Joyce at Trinity
College in Dublin and so he and I really
got along and he he helped my writing a
lot